our world changed a year ago before the
game a poignant and for some an
emotional moment one year ago today
george floyd was killed
and a show of unity and change in the
twins organization with a moment of
silence before the game jose is making
his temp start of the season 125th of of
his career
and in this ballgame we like to see
brielle's
locking in stand focus and executing the
game plan well here we go burrillos and
mullins and we are ready to play
baseball in minnesota
holland smacks one the other way that is
a fair ball up the line and ticketed for
the corner
cedric mullins a leadoff double and on
the third pitch of the game the orioles
explode against barrios well when cedric
was in the 350 range early on he could
do this
on command
and it's just a fast ball outside the
corner of the plate stays on top of it
two strikes to calvin three strikes
one away after mullen saw a fastball
after fastball galvez saw more breaking
balls and brielle strikes out his 57th
batter of the season well and that's
what brios has in a situation like that
swinging like that looked like galveston
not even really just trying to make
contact with it and chased the ball down
and in the dirt anthony santander two on
one out no score full count and the
payoff pitch a swing and a missed strike
three on a fastball at 95. kept that
sinker down and santander strikes out
swinging so two outs both by the
strikeout both swinging pick off play at
second oh and mullins is back in safely
and simmons believes they got him and
this one was close as mullins had a big
lead off second base simmons came from
behind the throw from barrios had plenty
on it and it pulled simmons glove into
the body and he's going to be out
because the right hand of mullins as he
dove back in was on the cleat of simmons
and the twins are going to win this
challenge here's the call and he's out
so barrios picks off cedric mullins as
dean kramer comes out to the mountain he
faces kepler donaldson and kiriloff to
kick things off in the bottom of the
first inning at target field three
fastballs two curves to start on 3-2
kepler it's a fastball into the shift
and stevie wilkerson fighting the
sunshine yeah
yeah we told you it's not an easy
sunfield look at that so i you know he
not only sees it but then flags it down
and this ball is a bullet up and in and
it just turns on it hits it really hard
right into the shift 102 miles per hour
two balls two strikes two outs bases
loaded second inning no score pitch in
and he will ground one through the right
side franco is in mount castle coming
around third no throw home a two-run
single for cedric mullins the orioles
make the twins pay and jump in front of
the second twins down two a two ball one
strike count to polanco there's a high
fly right field into the wind deep it
goes and go on now the left-handed swing
looked great there a long home run from
the all-star jorge polanco and the twins
answer back and now trail 2-1 talk about
ref schneider taking advantage of
his opportunity he's been given deep to
right center field chasing it as mullins
and that ball's off the wall garber got
a good break he'll be wheeled around
third heading home rob ref schneider has
done it again
and with one out on the second the twin
strike for at least a pair 2-2 game two
outs and that one gets away from
severino to the backstop rep snyder
scores and the twins take a 3-2 lead on
a curveball nowhere near home plate
severino had to leave his crouch rise
extend could not catch it twins by one
in the dirt this one gets away
another run scores simmons is in kepler
to third it's a 4-2 twins lead another
wild pitch
twins by two shift is on here against
severino
that was a middle middle pitch driven
out to right carol off looking up and
it's off the wall
wilkerson coming around third severino
booking it for second he is safe close
to a home run he'll take two and an rbi
for severino the orioles back within a
run another chance here to do some
damage in the fourth
high ball deep down the right field line
santander in the corner
and the warning track makes the catch
and coming in from third is ref
schneider and donaldson does
deliver a sacrifice slide
and the leads back to two
20th run batted in for donaldson and now
carroll up with a man at first and two
down
a blast to right center field
chasing it is mullins and it's off the
wall hero off with a double rounding
third coming home simmons to the plate
and he is out and let's hope he's okay
severino
reached up
and put the tag on him and simmons never
did touch home plate he tried to leap
over the tag
and is tagged out into two hits already
two down one on lefty lefty match-up
fuel bar
short fly ball center field
ref snyder lays out and makes the catch
they're in the inning rif snyder doing
it with his bat and now with his glove
here's kierloff one and two
hit to the left field corner
and that's down for a hit
donaldson rounding third he's going to
score
kerala with his second double and the
twins at a run
with an opposite field double by alex
caraloff
his 15th rbi all two strikes against
stewart here comes
stewart puts it in the air left center
field and deep heading back is ref
snyder and this ball is gone for the
second night in a row in the eighth
inning dj stewart goes deep as he takes
colemay out of the yard and makes it a
6-4 ball game
rogers
perhaps was
going to be asked to pitch the ninth
inning but now he's got to clean up the
eighth rogers
and the rest of the twins bullpens had a
tough time with inherited runners and
trying to leave valencia at second
wilkerson at first and get after mullins
tap right side
quickly to sono who barely got to the
bag
polanco flipped it to him and he picked
it off his hip for the third out
the orioles get one but leave two rogers
gets the job done on just a handful of
pitches and should be ready to go in the
night bottom eight twins batting leading
six to four prep snyder leads off
to right field and deep
back ref snyder
does it again
his third extra base hit of the knight
getting a chance to play and having the
time of his life ground goal the tying
run for the orioles in the ninth inning
no balls and two strikes
tapper
rogers fields
and finishes the game and the twins win
the game 7-4